реформа правосуддя табору чи з
корупцією в Україні
намажу та виду полицях їм прокуратуру
вчили я віктор шокін
такі нарікання довелося звіти
учасникам делегацією бундестагу зараз
перебування в Україні вид граматики
хактивістів
сам цьому набряки депутат норберт
шпинат за владним незнанням загорнув на
цілого в українського президента зараз
зустрічі
поршень клапан порошенка у нашому розмаху
за поважаючий dc пройдусь їм про
оновлення системи
мовляв для боротьби з корупцією та україни
прокурор тому для неї ванни і ви вирішували
ну заміна у неї та особи путін віктор
шокін його особливо ним старі системи про
таку владно виступав майдан повного
пари завантаження хочете на заході так
кличе ставку генпрокурора вже вставив і
ви слова тася на наш чайний так у лиж
не посли США в Україні та віце-президент
джо байден пі година грудна ви пощастило
туди до його черв'яних промо вас там за
іклам до кадрові зміни ВГП біля столу і
вид ставка міністра економіки айварас
абромавічус а френдшипи сф раніше дружба
дружбою та бізнес бізнесом вона політика та
країна то її народ понад усе теж osb
одягаючись ще президент без проблем по
просто виправити ставку
ти двох людей та як я закликав as king in
a flash або хто хоче не послухається Петра
порошенка до курять громадянського
suspense твоє то українських та західних
політиків
нічну світові і закласти до віру захисних
партнерів колима виставляємо акри такуто
робом відсік партнери та друзі
партнерства та дружба вважають лев
похвали та заповненнях у любові на поки що
справа не партнери та друзі youtube це
дуже рано і вказує і на проблеми
томи жвавості їхнього ви вирішення ми
обожнюємо україну розвитку великого
виграють і люди вид ходу вид старих
ладних структур вигляді та тирит старих
крутих структур ніж чоловіки в цій
їх не заощадження рішення чого означають мільйон
ще курс президента і подальша частка
реформ в Україні